you have a new series too it's called
Citadel yes I do I love this I'm excited
about this what is it about it's on
Amazon Prime and it is a spy show it's
out there now you guys should check it
out it's a really great spy show it's
got Richard Madden Stanley Tucci me
um an amazing uh cost of people but it's
six episodes and it's
um a really sick show there's never been
anything at the scale of like action
stunts and of the production value of
the show but at the same time it has
real heart with characters like my
character and Richard's character have
drama we have history plus we have to
save the world and they have to do it
together all that it's so good because
of all of that is the action hard for
you like scenes like the extra scenes
are I feel like you're you're always in
things when you're doing stuff like that
so I like that I have done a lot of my
stunts my whole life but I've I've also
learned to do that because I mean I
started with you know smaller Bollywood
movies and we never had a stunt double
that was awesome oh gosh they're gonna
kill me for that clip oh I'm like wait
which oh okay that's me pole vaulting
over a horse
wait so I heard about this and we didn't
make it it didn't even make it and you
pulled
the horse yeah a stallion yeah that's a
big horse I mean I was rigged but yeah
still pole vaulting over still looks so
cool it looked amazing to be in the in
the show it lives on my on my phone I
watch it a couple of every couple of
days just to remind myself I'd remind
myself that I'm capable of that but I
love I love stones and I love I trust my
body a lot um I've had a lot of
experience doing it but you know working
with the Russo Brothers they have such
an amazing stunt team like look at all
the stuff they've done with
um the Marvel stuff and you know they
their stunt team taught us a lot we
trained it was a year and a half of
training and wow being prepared and
working on your body and learning like
there's so much so many stunts in this
but it makes you feel like such a sense
of achievement when you watch the show
and you're like wow like 80. I look bad
with me yeah and and I did a great job
yeah it was it was challenging but it
was gratifying too yeah
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]